juste avant on chante depuis le début et
j'ai une demande ah oui pendant la pause
d'une personne qui voudrait chanter avec
moi la chanson qui aime qui a été le son
de l'année pour nous c'est quand même
cliché
et il y a une personne qui veut la
chanter avec moi c'est mon fils
il est là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quiète
[Applaudissements]
l'avion n'aurait pas dû choisir cette
chanson
t'es la plus belle des étoiles parmi les
autres je vois que toi si tu te sens
comme dis-moi il me reste une place près
de moi le projecteur sur toi c'est plus
comment tu brilles dans le noir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour que tu partes dis-moi qu'est-ce que
j'ai fait bon sang qu'est-ce que je fais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
[Applaudissements]
ça fait plaisir
[Musique]
si vous avez pas mis la petite rallonge